very early on in New York City and the
kind of heyday of prank shows where
there were prank shows everywhere Punk'd
had been a huge hit on MTV and so
suddenly everybody needed to have prank
shows and I got hired for a Comedy
Central prank show pilot called roommate
wanted we all lived an enormous loft in
Tribeca and the way this show was gonna
work was we were gonna get people who
needed a place to live and then we were
gonna start [ __ ] with them they would
come into the place and be like whoa
whoa oh my god this is amazing
and we would engage in hours of insanity
towards back like real crazy nonsense
like the landlord would come up who's
mad at us and he had a hammer two of the
people in the house were a couple and so
they would get in a fight with each
other everything would just spiral out
of control and told a point where and
this happened in every single one of
these instances the person would begin
to cry I have to leave I I don't know
what's going on I feel like you guys are
[ __ ] with me it was my job to make it
seem normal I was like supposed to be
their friend eventually the mark would
be left alone in the apartment and the
crazy ex roommates would show up who the
[ __ ] are you this is my apartment you
think you're gonna let [ __ ] you man
people would just become inconsolably
sad at which point they would tell me
reveal it the cameraman would come out
and be like haha with the person tears
streaming down their face and me be like
hey you just got pranked you're on a
brand new show on Comedy Central called
roommate 1 and the PERT this only cause
the person to become more upset what is
this what are you talking about is this
apartment even for rent Lilly just move
here
and you guys all seem so nice if it's
just been really hard for me and and we
would be like oh no oh no it was
soul-crushing for us all of the cast we
would all in between the set ups just
sit on the set just kind of like oh this
is awful
but what instantly became clear was that
it's not just kind of some haha you're
shopping for pants people who need a
place to live are very vulnerable and so
the minute the first person showed up we
we all instantly realized oh no no no
this is this is a nightmare I would
argue this show should never get
remaining it and not surprisingly the
pilot was not picked up to series